welcome to this video round 2 coverage
from Tom Memorial 2013 and let's get
right to the games and starting with
kayaking against Carlton unfortunately
i'll be honest with you this wasn't very
exciting um and yeah we got the dreaded
Berlin variation of the off the reuleaux
PES it's a bit of a spoilsport line
really the problem is that probably the
only way the principled way for why this
the the Berlin Wall end game and this is
almost played out to death so they
mostly play the Sun um yeah they play
this this d3 line or they try what
kayaking is not trying this rookie one
line but this is as you can see leading
to a position where the e-file is open
this is quite similar to the French
exchange of course we haven't depons
play yet or some kind of petrov defense
we are very off from the file or pieces
are traded yeah default and God please
night to e8 this is some consider to be
a reliable move the idea to free the
deep horn and then play Bishop d6 Knight
f6 back and win the tempo on the rook I
cannot place d5 this idea has been
played before um also against them cards
and actually by Peter Leko and
non-vegans the earlier this year and in
fact despite ending in the drawer like
Oh got a little bit of something in this
game you got an endgame we could try for
quite a long while in this game
it's a bit different we have couple of
normal developing moose and we see that
black has got both bishops on the decent
squares is ready to play Knight f6 and
in general any advantage for white
certainly pretty small IAM initiated
this exchange now and Knight f6 and
night a for this is what white can try
to play for getting this Bishop for the
night and then try to prove that your
Bishop on c1 and this is potentially
going on the long diagonal like B 3 B
should be to this Bishop is a better
piece than the night this is certainly
the case where is it enough to to win a
game hmm let's see what what happened
yeah attacking the knight so actually
provoking the caption and here after c4
ruki 8 um it's very difficult to item
cannot avoid the trades really and so we
got rooks off yeah and now countin set
up a very sturdy defensive position he
brought the 936 since almost typical
blockading post like classical names of
each material it's not a blockade in the
sense that this is not a passed pawn
because the support on c7 but it's a
typical way to place your night to
always attack upon and why term still
retains a symbolic advantage the bishop
is still the better piece probably but
what what can you do here it's
completely symmetrical the spawn
structure and white has really no way
forward after a couple of more moves
here the draw was agreed I'm not a
terribly exciting game but um it's it's
difficult nowadays for those for the top
players who play 1.e4 to get anywhere
against the Berlin that seems to be
really a sort of dead end at the moment
kayaking is not one hundred percent
before player he sometimes varies with
d4c for stuff like that but he's
primarily a one year for player yeah not
too exciting what can you do um let's um
switch to the other games now and in
fact the other game super exciting
almost all of them I think actually all
of them um let's start with the moroso
which against my videographer and we got
a car walk on defense the caro-kann is
really am a really popular opening
nowadays on the top level and it also
pretty much has a reputation of being a
good weapon to to you have to play at
them in any for any kind of occasion
even if you want to win this black why
not go for the calc on Ted a pretty dry
and somewhat less exciting reputation
will be twenty years ago when Karpov was
playing the slot but nowadays lots of
variations are really a sharp and
interesting okay a moral place the
advanced usually does that and we got
the so-called short system with Bishop
e2 and white just developing slowly but
slowly it doesn't mean bad lame um yeah
here in this position Mammadyarov
actually plays a move that makes
slightly risky impression to be honest
he played the instant c5
this is of course possible not bad I'm
quite often instead black plays
prophylactic moves like Bishop to HSN
and this actually does make a lot of
sense the bishop is simply better placed
on edge tablet you are not getting hit
by a move like night to d4 Knight to h4
neither before we see after c5 DC 5 plus
90 for ideas maybe this is a better a
better version of the game where white
now will claim move not sure what can
only speculate let's say rookie one
throwing up the best myth and then I can
think about playing c5 again or first
plane moves like this and then play c5
what I'm getting at is this instance e5
proved to be somewhat risky why took
after this recap sure you can also look
at 96 by the way that's 94 this is
really a bit of an annoying move you
cannot really allow the capture there's
also be should be five in the mix so at
the Bishop to Bishop moved and normal
and now lied to be three and um yeah
here black already needs to be very very
cautious on in order not to get blown
away quickly what he played seems to be
a serious mistake but this is not so
easy to see at all he took on b3 he
didn't take on b3 I'm sorry I skipped a
move I'm sorry 96 okay Bishop e3 and now
now we get to the point I'm sorry here
we took on b3 and this really seems to
be very risky let's see what happens he
took on b3 anthem words which he
recaptured and the problem is that their
various ways now to increase the
pressure by white
if black now just goes for normal
developing moves like Bishop e7 for
example there's this move this is a
problem c6 hangs now and if black covers
that that's the very interesting move
Queen javan and yeah what is blacks
supposed to do now just threatening g7
and black has a really hard time to
cover that the big problem is the normal
looking move Bishop g6 is smashed by 96
and black on black is completely
completely toast now this kind of stuff
so this is a very strong thread Bishop
b5 Quincy form then black black is
really in trouble him what he did is he
grabbed the pawn this this move actually
seems to almost lose the game but i'm
not sure what black should do maybe I
think the computer actually gives this
line as the best giving up upon him or
first here sorry maybe this one it
doesn't really matter to give up a phone
in this in this fashion and giving wider
substantial edge but not the direct win
in the game he took only five which is
really really risky I mean not risky
it's probably just losing the game but
this is some isn't something that you
can calculate y ok Bishop g5 check is
the very logical response and played by
model 97 now and in fact here he
probably miscalculated something because
here white has a move that really wins
the game like a sister
what you played is excellent for white
as well but it's not instantly winning
it seems that the move Queen gphone
again is basically winning the game
Black has this threat to worry about and
there's basically no way to to prevent
it I mean that thing you can prevent
this one but then there are other ideas
you can cover this pawn with Queenie 7
but this is just answered by rookie one
and the idea is just Bishop f4 and 96
and black is helpless he cannot do
anything to to prove to defend this the
relatively best move with Bishop to g8
and this really looks looks sick that's
a very famous game by David Bronstein
where he played Bishop GA dinner
caro-kann enter actually at the end got
a good position but okay this is not
this position here why the tag is
enormous um a possible line is c4 here
and it seems to be that like has no no
way to defend this one idea is that
after this let's say this white just
wins by X by sacrificing a piece like I
certainly not playing with all those
pieces and this look here coming and
it's a disaster who does climbing on
plus seven or something so it's probably
very close to to a checkmate um yeah
Quincy for was very strong what he
played is good as well but it doesn't
seem to win outright a more loose which
played Queen to h5 which is threatening
the same move because of the the pin but
here it seems that black can barely
admittedly barely hanging on to to
continue the game Bishop g6 and 25 he
probably saw exactly that and saw that
this Queen move here is very very tricky
to meet but black has exactly one move
and this defense played them going to be
eight it's funny motif on queen bee six
yeah which doesn't look too bad at first
that's the funny move route takes a
seven quite quite nice like takes now on
a seven with the Queen that's 96 winning
a note that the queen is attacked and
our kinds of discoveries are are
threatened lift rook takes there's this
funny move then at the end the rook is
falling and this also 95 coming so
completely disaster but okay instead of
Queen B 6 that is Queen B 8 and this
really am yeah keeps the game going it's
not winning any more wide exchange and
took a seven and of course it's obvious
that white still has the better game
he's got those very strong pieces that
are simply more active and this is still
an issue I mean against them substandard
defense on by black white can certainly
hope to to win the game and he still has
something but then as it as it went um
Mammadyarov played a couple of very good
defensive moves Bishop t6 and King e7
keeping this night protected and
preparing to use the rook and a very
important idea was that after f4 which
looks very logical going for the
battering ram f4 f5 there's Bishop
before which is very important to get
this Bishop on the strong square and
allow that after f5 you can play a five
and I think here black and some is
basically okay yeah well black might be
okay but right still can try to
complicate matters and Rose which is
just the right player for doing that you
played no f6 check getting f5 for the
night and what is black supposed to do
now the instant reaction would be Knight
f6 but there's knight c6 this is a funny
technical idea using the rook on the 7th
so on like needs to tape with the pawn
not much choice and then there's not a
fact this was the idea sacrificing a
porn but getting the bishops in the
process and okay this double porn isn't
exactly great so I'm white certainly has
some compensation for the porn but it's
not enough to really um yeah get to to a
position of firm of a serious advantage
this is the good defensive maneuver
getting the night 36 and intending to
play deform blacks got a couple of nice
central pawns and you want to push those
of course yeah Bishop c6 text coupons
and black is pushing forward young yeah
but who could also take it and simply
and not so much going on black black has
an extra porn I mean it's not the
strongest porn ever but he's got nicely
centralized pieces says also this in
five square for the bishop if necessary
and even if he loses the beep on this is
a doubled youporn so it's just in
essence it is just one beep on
not not to so I don't think that black
really has got any problems the engine
even gives black a minimal preference
and one or two positions that dries but
it's really nothing serious like I can
never win this game really so ya see
that this fashion black keeps would an
extra prom but okay it's not very strong
am I mean this is a good a black doesn't
have an extra pawn I'm i miss counting
this and sorry um so it's a it should be
should be about equal but we still get
in a funny position slightly later and
this is here after after this it's quite
quite funny that black takes the the
bishop and he also had the opportunity
to play King g7 intending f6 trapping
this bishop and this was really possible
and whiter needs to be M quite precise
to UM to hold this f6 is a serious right
what actually seems have only one news
this is real this is king of one the
ideas that Bishop c5 was always a check
and you want to go to a 5-2 answer f6
with luke t 1 and this with the idea of
playing group t7 seems to UM seems to be
good enough for a draw at the end but
then it's shaky black should try that it
seems that the best try a [ __ ] I
wanna say hi to c5 this keeps this idea
the position but I text the bishop first
and something like Bishop to c6 f6 rook
to d1 Bishop to d7 and then taking and
b7 seems to be sufficient for a very
narrow but for a draw the the issue is
that this is very advanced in spawn and
white will get the F for porn so we've
got he's got two points and probably
will always be able to exchange the last
pawn that blacks got and the best he can
hope for is for cement game with two
pieces against one so this is probably
ending in a draw in the game he just
took the bishop I think you should have
tried it really to play King g7 but ok
this is no problem at all and
considering that Mammadyarov was
basically lost in the opening it's
certainly nice to to have such an
endgame that you can never lose so after
a couple of moves they agree to wrong
p.m. that's simply no way forward sorry
no way forward for black the only way f3
or something is it's simply not working
technically so we have a repetition
there's also f5 of course hanging so
what what does you can try that but look
at this don't want to want to experience
that so a draw at the end and a mr.
opportunity for Rosa Beach with Queen G
for this position Queen g4 was
exceptionally strong ok so let's go to
the next game and this is under aching
against term are not we can tell semi
Slav one of alan's main weapons of
against you for the plate an excellent
game
in January this year against Aronian
probably one of his most particular wins
and he also has got very positive
memories of the semis laughs against
them kramnik in their World Championship
match in Germany 2008 so this opening is
also a short candidate to pop up in the
World Championship match in case Magnus
place deform okay so Queen d3 this is a
rare line played by undertaking but this
is in fact quite interesting the idea of
the smoothest to play a quickie form and
this is really only possible with the
screen move the idea for instance let's
say black place this you have the
opportunity to play for you don't
necessarily need to do that now but this
is one IDM and this is quite interesting
this this line I think the main drawback
is what yeah it's the line that that
unemployed but we quickly get to some
rather unexplored position he took and
then played a b5 gaining a tempo on the
Queen yeah blacks ideas to to win this
temple and then use those can be to
develop on the queenside ceux qui needs
to retreat of course and now be should
be seven run before attacking be for
later and dislodging the snide so it's a
technical issue night moves and queen a5
instantly attacking the knight b3 and
here this position has been had been
reached before couple of times but the
move played now by Anand is is very
sharp and only has been played once
before this is a c5 instantly attacking
the pawn the main problem is and this is
highlighted by
and Reagan's move 925 is that a check on
b5 is a very unsettling um unsettling
move from black and we see that the
rising positions now look extremely
dangerous hope like extremely dangerous
so on let's um let's look 95 he took on
deform and quimby five check this was
the idea we need changed and now of
course king is f the only move otherwise
you you lose material instantly night
b27 is something you can check but this
looks rather problematic he played King
to e7 and yeah Black has one upon this
default point and is attacking before so
I material went a few plaque is fine but
the King only seven that's really really
ugly blocking this bishop and I mean
what what does this piss doing only
seven the amazing thing is that the
coming moves now are really excellent by
both players I think just represent some
optimal claim a nun tookie for and he
was playing this quickly so maybe he was
still in preparation while and ranking
was on its own Bishop e2 sacrificing
another pawn and island took that as
well she won and now Bishop c6e I played
that this is really a spectacular move
he played Bishop to c6 now this is a
move you can easily overlook I mean that
it is even a playable move you can
easily overlook the the cool idea is
that becoming King b6 attacks to pieces
in the game he took him but there's also
this idea
and black get support a piece back it's
actually two blacks advantage already
when he played was was right he took
here and now white being a piss-up but
King d6 attacking two nights and black
will get a piece Baggins it's really
really a remarkable sequence and the fun
thing is if you look at this now why did
God rook see one this is also the best
move again and now of course Kings e6
you need to get your piece back and
white is even allowed discovery but that
is slow really excellent one took only
six now King back and yeah what does
some whites supposed to do now it is
attacked and while he took on evade
which is not really what you want to do
with this well-traveled night to
exchange a piece still on the back rank
but night XD form is really not the
leading leading too much templayer this
was check or even night before to see
three can be considered walking this
bishop in the game this better he just
took on f8 rook takes and here he took
on oops took on the form and there was
also look she's happened but it seems
after we ate kings and rookie form that
blacks got in a cafe enough activity so
covering this for the moment and intends
to get counter play against the week
pawns should be about equal he took on
d4 this is this is also good and now I
think an ant is playing the only in
precise move of the game they both
played played excellent game i think
they drew k to see a true create seems
to be better rooks yet has a slight
slight drawback but unlike in with
little time on the clock didn't
didn't exploit it he just took on c8 but
it seems that instead look T 1 was the
more interesting move intending this
deserve is move and after I'm King move
and say here this route g7 it's not the
end of the world for black but it's
maybe you should go to e6 actually maybe
slightly better in comparison yeah
something like this is probably better a
rook endgame black should really hold
there are various route look and games
now being a will porn down something
like this look to hear this for example
but black it needs to be active here
cannot play with gate or something but
you need to be reactive king or maybe
maybe book g2h to white is better no
question but black has got chances to do
to the active King something like this
probably would have happened if he had
played rook to d1 and not exchange after
the exchange it really is wrong after a
couple of moves we get a pawn in game
and black is just too active there's
also a 5a for we see this in the game
also coming yeah yeah and now we have
fun
a very elementary end game where you
have zero chances of scoring when even
without the f porn it's a draw okay
interesting game I think they played if
you look at it with what the computer
you see that and they didn't make any
substantial mistakes so very good game
ok let's some turn to caruana against
Gelfond and to be honest I have F on a
serious problem with this game um my
problem is that almost all of the game
is some is obviously known known theory
and the the only thing I could do
because right after they leave the known
moves the game is basically decided what
i could do is to invest a couple of
hours and make a theoretical overview of
this line but i simply don't have the
time so i try to present that roughly
this is this opening phase got a night
off and come on i'll place the the
English attack with quick long castles
and f3b should be three white intends to
pawn store in an ideal world but off
needs to combine it with the central
play because black is coming with b5 as
well we get this line where the funny
point is that like an answer g5 with B
form and after ninety to ninety eight
let's move f4 and I know that this has
been played almost I think I found
around 40 games which is still quite
amazing yeah it is forced now and in a
way after I've formed as a 5 f-5 almost
wrapping the bishop it it could go to to
c4 but this was not the idea the idea
was to play a phone which was so done in
the game takes only six takes on v3 yeah
now in this position of you if you
the night this this one and new queen is
coming so it's not not possible white
just recaptured on p3 and black to
Bonnie six all this has been played and
more than once actually we should be a
free rook takes on a tool to show you
six check to my mind this is really some
crazy chest but it has been played a
couple of times before and in fact it
seems to be around equal the only
problem is well aware no no I'm
realizing that the time spent kawana was
blitzing all this so he was following
preparation but what the heck is he
doing a couple of moves ok so let's see
what happened then the bishop hang so
moved it away go into a 8 this is
looking at the spawn and making this
look mobile look f1 took it Jack gave
the check to exchange really this has
been played before it's a it's all known
and d5 even this has been known and look
at kiwanis clock he has more time here
then he had at the beginning of the game
so he deliberately went for this
position it seems and now he played the
move h4 ah he spent nine minutes on that
but the curious thing is if you go for
this and now play h4 after deform that's
what girl from played black is already
substantially better and it's not
exactly difficult to spot I mean what
what is why i doing in this position i
really don't understand the game because
blacks gotten past power now okay this
is not directly promoting or anything
but it is a passed pawn a protected one
black scott ideas with night e 62 f for
attacking efore with 95 all kinds of
stuff and what is why it's play
I mean if you give it to an engine it
instantly gives black a substantial
advantage after default like more than
harbour porn so this is simply a
terrible kind of I don't know maybe he
screwed up move on us or something in
the opening this is just just terrible
Rep reducing some some previous game and
then you're then you're worse instead of
this age for it seems that white should
should take and this is probably about
equal without I don't really want to go
into detail analysis of this but it
seems to be seen ok but after this
deform white is really am in big trouble
Bishop 31 and 96 we already see that
this is coming this is coming there are
tons of ideas for black but what it's
white doing it's got the silly Bishop
here and no attacked whatsoever yeah
Queenie to and tonight d to see Five
Quincy form and this position he played
a night f4 which is not bad but here
black had a very strong continuation but
this was difficult to find by now Kara
wanna was was spending time realizing
that he's in big trouble here black had
a very strong continuation by the
difficult to find when this is h6 and
after taking black can really take on on
edge for the taking is not the best move
but I want to see I want to show the
point the point is that this is actually
playable yeah because of course this is
this year yeah it's a disaster
but h6 is a very computer ish move that
human hardly things about I think it
really is not necessary what government
played that was keeping a big edge there
was also Queen a1 also with the big
advantage okay night f form and Queen to
f7 we never ate yeah here probably you
should go for the end game but it's ugly
of course Quincy for i went back didn't
want to exchange no g six ozs usefulness
yeah TM um one problem is if you take
here there's naught F 2d three
check yeah white skin position is really
ugly something like this is as a
possible line yeah h5 ISM a good move
difficult move giving black some some
room for the king and a black is this
better here if white for example tries
this check this Bishop of 8 and now it's
very difficult to find a movie take here
but I can really just take there is no
perpetual or anything like answers just
winning yeah in the game we played
Bishop to f2 with little time of a clock
but this in fact just loses immediately
due to more than one move actually but
this is strong 92 always visually
attractive to put your piece on a square
where this protected three times the
square but the hits it's just the
winning move what can you do Queen takes
us the easiest running into this fog if
the night takes oops test still this
with d3 this is hanging it is a stem and
the bishop takes also leaves this
attacked and that's also d3 threatened
this is protecting each other very nice
day and the Queen cannot really enter
anywhere to get the counter player just
all too quick here with checks and
everything so very bad position so after
92 white cannot really take you played
the funky move Knight to h1 likes knives
in the corner always funny yeah but just
d3 and Queen f3 and it's very ugly yeah
girl font executed this nicely not a
form gap this Queen B 2 coming
yeah and I think he resigned not empty
we just played on a couple of months
Yeah right here resigned as so it's a
good good finishing touch let's have a
look briefly at ya check check and at
the end you just take him it's
everything's protected it's just one
check and then why does running out of
steam rather rather quickly so I'm
completely a disastrous opening result
by kawana I can only see I have no idea
what year what the idea was maybe he was
intending to play something before and
and forgot it I don't know no I was
really shocked to see that all this
happened before and then this rather bad
move h4 is the novelty no idea what
happened there but a very nice win by
girlfriend I mean it's not his problem
if the opponent plays them yeah somebody
furia novelty so nice win by them
current down runner-up of the last world
championship match so this leaves one
game Kramnik nakamura those games always
fun I think from magma camera it's a bit
of a clash of conflicting styles where
Nakamura very often goes for this rather
wild and hard to to judge complications
and chronic is get usually mr. solid
playing very sophisticated and and
sometimes technical chess yeah let's see
what happened in this game also note
that both players lost in the first
round Nakamura with white this rather
awful game against mamedyarov
got wiped out quickly and chronic lost
his end game against cars so they both
certainly don't really want to lose I
mean you really want to but this is not
a great position to lose to start with 0
points out of two games yeah we get a
king's indian fianchetto i'm not sure
that Nakamura some has played this
before both players don't have much
experience here I think with the
position yeah Kramnik played be three
you too sir rambles it may be designed
to prevent some simple grid lines the
normal move actually is efore or a tree
but before the Sun allows some sharp
Alliance here with a six for example
maybe he wanted to just own twist moves
on to us move on as a bit rupee 8 plate
deform c6 looks like a very normal
position from the fianchetto Kings
Indian and here Kramnik played an
exceptionally rare move surprisingly he
is really I'm one of the most creative
players nowadays in the opening
presenting all kinds of um lesser-known
and not so explored moves Bishop e3 the
normal theoretical move would be aged 3
this is just a typical preparation move
for this and in fact this is a line
where black has scored terribly but this
is some the case for this general kind
of line the classical can shatter with
c66 night bd7 there's pretty dreadful
results and the love them in the past of
let's ln last 10 20 years the only
player who's caught decently with the
Cyrillic
bar off everything else just everybody
else really AM had two big problems okay
but Bishop e3 is chrome next move the
interesting thing is that here to the
sub tech there's also this reg this is
why h3 is such a common booth I'm here
white played f3 so it's a different idea
of simply protecting the center with f3
and white enjoyed this can of no Roxy
bind an important feature of the
position is if black ones to play d5 are
not wants to play certainly wants to but
if he actually does then there's this
neat little trick with white winning an
important pawn okay this didn't happen
Queenie 7 was played ok 185 Quincy to
let's just put this back to be honest I
have the slight problem with this
position that I absolutely dislike
blacks position and I have some some
problems to suggest the proper plan here
what is pretty clear if you look at the
next two or three mooses that Nakamura
awesome play wasn't so great but I'm not
really sure what what the right way to
go about this is if you look at the
computer recommendation you see some
weird stuff I mean the computer um wants
to wants to play moves like 97 to e5 and
then back and to be six and it doesn't
really have any big plan here my problem
with this position from the black side
is that I'm not really sure what kind of
porn push and playing form I cannot play
really d5 very difficult kind of move
the beat porn I cannot move anything on
the Kings and I'm basically sitting
there with less space and trying to sort
of play players
of guerrilla war trying to disturb white
with pieces and those little jabs like a
4-h 5h for and it's very tricky to play
her I really not sure what black should
do what I know is Bishop e6 wasn't
really the way to go would be one and
now he played a 4 which was the idea
obviously but this leads to a terrible
position the thing is what should you
play instead of instead of a form it's
um it's really am that's really not nice
white can if everything else failed to
take the bishops say look here but
there's also other moves yeah i know i'm
slightly biased i simply don't like
black position because i don't know what
what plan you you're playing for maybe
you can drop the bishop back now if you
don't take it but but this simply this
simply is better for white it's two
bishops the space why this better I'm
not really sure I think there should be
six is not great really this can also be
seen by the computer recommendation if
you give this to adini it spits out
Bishop to see eight which its slight
indication that maybe we should be six
wasn't so great okay he played a for
this was the idea the bad thing about
this yet this move basically throws the
game away it's just before I don't
really understand it to be honest before
97 back what what else now it took only
six took a four and that's it white one
upon and here we change them strategical
advantages the idea was of a technical
nature with 95 so it's not i'm not what
I'm saying is Nakamura didn't simply
blunder the pawn yet some idea but it
doesn't seem to work out here txt now c4
and you cannot protect it with the
letter O
Bishop everyone has this is hanging with
check so c5 also move you you like to
play of course why not and queen to see
form this was probably the IDM but White
has got the very simple actually but
often simple moves as are the ones that
you are missing most easily queen bee
three this is the simple but but good
move and yeah what is flex compensation
now your porn down um don't really have
any kind of IDM what you want to play
does he took on c5 and in this position
now I think Kramnik I could have one
instantly or let's say instantly is a
bit unfair mean winning him tactically
it said I understand why I didn't play
it but FY it's move he certainly
calculated no doubt about that but maybe
he thought the the way he played was
actually easier but it doesn't it
doesn't really seem to be the case here
blacks relatively best arm seems to be
group takes a form Queen takes b3 a b3
night and Bishop c5 is just lost its a
pawn to Bishop c5 coming Knight b6
coming this is guns don't need to be
chronic to win that so the only vague
ideas some sort of sacrifice let's say
we pay for trying to complicate matters
if Y it now takes on a four that's 93
it's still not working but it's some
some sort of idea and another idea but
also not the one not
one that is actually working is f'd xe5
tags tags here Dwight grabs this piece
and at the end it's just a piece lube
takes be three black and continue for a
bit he's got two points but it's it's
really a technical win form for a good
player those pawns are not advancing
quickly really um yeah I think probably
kramnik believed he he won anyway not
not only with this f4 idea yeah but the
one that did he played maybe he assessed
a similarly good he just played the
queer Knight b6 and this forces the
Queen trade and still has the rug
attacked Brooke moved you don't have a
good square really go to the eighth and
now here and yeah how to assess this
position yeah widest is completely
winning of course it's a poem it's two
bishops it's an irritating night the
camera plate 97 and here I'm Kramnik
played 94 which is perfectly all right
you also could have taken on d 7 which
is maybe the simplest approach just
exchanged some pieces 94 though is it's
a good idea the thing is blacks got two
nights that are actually standing on
each other's toes a bit and this is the
argument for 49 f 49 to f8 and I think
the next move is probably not the best
one it seems that maybe King f 1 e 2 is
better but root g6 it looks normal using
this this square but 96 bishop f8 is
some rather natural and not so easy to
counter
96 was played look T 1 and Luke to aah
yeah and in this position um it is
already not so easy it is not so easy I
think them at least an interesting
continuation now would have been to play
F for him now g4 and then drop it back
the idea is to play Bishop f85 and this
is some rather strong exchange stack of
course not difficult but it's it's
strong if black takes d6 you recapture
and you can actually think about which
was the best one this is probably better
and you gotta get a very strong passport
got the bishops which are both excellent
and those night cm this can be pushed
back then Bishop e3 Bishop b6 why does
still matter him ramnik probably did
some miscalculation in the in the game
continuation he certainly saw that this
is a good line he played h3 preparing f4
yeah trying to cut this night but now
Nakamura has got this trick and he's not
the kind of player who overlooks those
those funny little tricks and after this
hmm it's already already a bit tricky
took almost all kinds of stuffing so
what needs to take okay for and now
Bishop fa to c5 and black is in the game
again it's quite remarkable you really
return from the dead here would be 7 and
covering b7 Bishop f8 like is intending
to get the pawn and then there would be
materially quality all of a sudden now
here we go yeah now the question is what
to do with this Bishop white um
can't really exchange this is quite
obviously bad because it gives black
this very strong right on c5 and this
attack against before so why it needs to
avoid the trade and he played bishops if
one it seems that Bishop b2 is stronger
Bishop see one needs two leads to some
trouble now maybe even trouble that
white cannot really resolve the problem
is that this Bishop is is really not
very well placed a truck ahead and now
there's roop a one coming on Brooke a to
coming and it's already very tricky if
white plays a slow move yeah let's say H
form it's also simply this is born is
hanging yeah for chronic with the clock
ticking down as some as it very often
happens tries to play in the most
aggressive fashion you played f5
attacking the knight it's probably also
on not too bad but it's not really
working out at the end night f8 look
back it was attacked and now nakamura
simply took the porn and yeah it's now
porn up and where exactly is White's
great compensation the problem is you're
playing with them with this really silly
looking bishop the night is is
controlling important squares and this
is a very strong piece and yeah well
this is rather strong around here it is
probably already too late to suggest
anything for chrome like this Bishop see
one loses bad and of course he allowed
this trick which really turn to taunt
the game and get it turned it on its
head iam okay you should h6 and nakamura
now is playing this very accurately
pushing the pawns
Dwight ridium doesn't have any any big
counterplay it's the bad thing it is you
really tried hard but now this night
helps and the defense ok that's an
attack on f7 but winning a little tempo
and now just push the porn the porn on
f7 is not important anymore why took it
anyway and then Luke to be eight black
also could have taken on you five was
also strong but Luke pietas fairly
logical pushing the porn or supporting
this pawn push it back and roots III it
was hanging and now black just promotes
it's quite funny allowed this and played
on for for a couple of moves with the
Queen down but then we quickly got ya
this material transformation and now
black is a piece up and nothing
crumbling probably being very
disappointed played on a couple of moves
but not quite sure how long we played on
our here he actually here we designed
really yeah well this is what what the
ICC says yeah it's quite them quite
weird yeah of course I mean this is of
course winning no question but it's a
bit with uncommon to resign after you
you have just moved um yeah a very very
tough loss for chronic of course I mean
this is the kind of game well you really
don't understand probably what what's
going on at first because well it's
really recognizable that why does
winning here and it's still tricky
obviously need to be a plate precisely
and he simply didn't didn't play this
move this is the sharpest move that
probably wins wins this instant
in the game of course this I mean you
actually would expect that chrome League
wins deserve in his sleep but he somehow
managed to even now even though bring
this to a position where you can lose
and actually he did lose a very bad
start of course for Kramnik this
tournament losing two games the first
two games probably and he never ever
lost the first two games and tournament
cannot really imagine how this should
have happened probably in some I don't
know under under 12 regional
championship or so maybe it never
happened to him okay so after two rounds
we have from kramnik with no point zero
points and my camera on fifty percent
again the tournament leaders are Gelfond
cards and and and and who won in the
first round gelfand cards and
Mammadyarov of course he won this
attacking game against nakamura but
didn't forget something all right I hope
you enjoyed this coverage of round 2
i'll be back with the next round
tomorrow thanks for watching